because absolutely anything is possible
in the year 2020 the governor of new
york andrew cuomo is coming out with a
new book
bragging about how he responded to the
coronavirus
well joining us now is jaina steen she's
our senior meteorologist here at fox
news sadly her in-laws died in nursing
homes
in new york state because of the
policies that andrew cuomo backed we
should also say that janisteen
is one of the most honest people we know
and therefore one of our favorite guests
happy to ever on tonight
janice thanks for coming on i'm just
gonna throw it to you what's your
response to this book
i couldn't believe it when i found out
just a couple of months ago that he had
time
to write a book in the middle of a
pandemic
i mean what governor would have time to
do that
i mean it's incredible i actually
thought it was a satire from the babylon
b
when i saw that he was writing a book
about his leadership
taking a victory lap for flattening the
curve the curve that had my
in-laws on it he has lost more people
in new york from coronavirus on his
watch than any other state over 33 000
people have died
and including my in-laws we still don't
have the actual
total number of deaths from seniors
getting coveted in their
assisted living facilities or their
elder care facilities
because his uh representative his
nursing
uh home representative his health uh
commissioner will not give us the
accurate totals
of those that died in hospitals like my
mother-in-law so
there are all these unanswered questions
that we have
uh about his leadership that he has not
answered in his so-called book
did you expect him to apologize sincere
question
i'm not sure um it's
up until this point he hasn't apologized
i think in the very beginning
tucker if he had taken some
accountability and said i was trying to
save some of the hospital beds for the
patients that we needed
uh and that's why i made that mistake of
putting covet positive patients into
nursing homes for 46 days by the way
if he had done that in the very
beginning but he never has and by the
way he's blamed everyone else except the
person that signed the executive order
andrew cuomo it was in effect for 46
days
he's blamed god and mother nature and
the president and the cdc and the new
york post and fox news he's blamed
everyone except the person that signed
the mandate the order
putting those coveted positive patients
into nursing homes
that's what gets my blood boiling he
still refuses to acknowledge that
the other day in one of the interviews
he actually said we didn't need to put
covet positive patients into nursing
homes and i screamed
it just makes our grief even worse
tucker
i couldn't agree more you know all of us
make mistakes we made mistakes on this
show
but you know a man's character by the
reaction next people who blame others
and don't apologize for their mistakes
it's the lowest and i'm sorry that you
had to suffer the consequences your
family genestein thank you for joining
us tonight
i appreciate it thank you tucker thank
you for having me on